OUT.
I MEAN --
>> GOT YOU.
GREAT INTERVIEWS OF ALL TIME.
HE'S GOT A NEW BOOK, "12 RULES
FOR LIFE."
TRUTH TELLER.
ONE OF THE CHAPTERS IS "TELL THE
TRUTH."
THAT IS ONE OF YOUR RULES.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE THINGS YOU
THINK WE ARE FORCED TO LIE ABOUT
IN THIS MOMENT.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF WE ARE
FORCED.
I THINK WOULD MAKE A CHOICE.
IT IS SOMETIMES A BETTER CHOICE,
BUT THAT IS OFTEN THE CHOICE.
YOU ARE SOMETIMES IN A SITUATION
WHERE YOU ARE IF YOU DO AND
IF YOU DON'T, MIDAS WILL PICK
THE POISON YOU WOULD RATHER YOU
TAKE, YOU HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO SAY SOMETHING
UNPOPULAR AND GET A TACTIC FOR
IT, THAT IS A RISK, BUT TO
PRETEND YOU THINK SOMETHING
DIFFERENT IS TO WARP YOUR SOUL
AND THERE IS A MUCH BIT TO MAKE
I WOULD THINK THAT EVEN IF THEY
DON'T AGREE WITH YOU, PEOPLE IN
THE WAY YOU RESPOND, CLEARLY YOU
ARE SAYING WHAT YOU THINK, AND
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE OUR
CHARGE AS JOURNALISTS, TO SAY
THE TRUTH.
YOU GET MET WITH THESE HOSTILE
RECEPTIONS.
UNIVERSAL.
THERE IS A BIG BATTLE IN THE
INTERVIEW.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE CASTING
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN MANY PEOPLE
IN THE MEDIA WHO STOOD WITH IT
AND SAID IT IS NECESSARY TO BE
ABLE TO SAY WHAT YOU THINK.
IT IS NOT YET, IT IS GOOD.
SURPRISING BUT GOOD.
>> Tucker: SO IF YOU, IN THE
BOOK, YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF THESE
RULES, AND WILL 5 JUMPED OUT AT
ME AS A FATHER.
HERE IS THE RULE.
"DON'T LET YOUR CHILDREN DO
ANYTHING THAT MAKES YOU DISLIKE
THEM.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> IT MEANS YOU SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU ARE CAPABLE
OF DISLIKING YOUR CHILDREN AND
THAT BECAUSE YOU ARE LARGER AND
MORE POWERFUL THAN THEM, IF YOU
PUT THE MISBEHAVE IN A WAY THAT
MAKES YOU DISLIKE THEM, YOU ARE
GOING TO TAKE REVENGE ON THEM IN
A BAD WAY, SOMETIMES OVER
DECADES, I HAVE SEEN THAT AS
A CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST.
MORE IMPORTANT, IF YOUR CHILDREN
BELIEVE
BEHAVE IN WAYS THAT MAKE YOU
DISLIKE THEM, ASSUMING YOU ARE
REASONABLE, AND THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING YOU WANT TO DISCUSS
TOO, OTHER ADULTS, THEN THEY
WON'T TEACH THEM THINGS, THEY
WON'T PAY ATTENTION TO THEM, AND
THEY WILL ONLY SMILE FALSELY AT
THEM, AND OTHER CHILDREN WILL
WANT TO PLAY WITH THEM AND
INCLUDE THEM.
THAT IS A CATASTROPHE FOR YOUR
CHILD.
IT IS VERY HELPFUL TO HELP YOUR
CHILDREN BEHAVE IN WAYS THAT
MAKE OTHER PEOPLE WELCOME THEM
BECAUSE THEN EVERYWHERE THEY GO,
THEY ARE WELCOME, AND THERE IS
NOTHING BETTER YOU CAN DO FOR A
CHILD THAN THAT.
>> Tucker: VERY SMART.
IN THE MINUTE WE HAVE LEFT, IF
YOU COULD PASS ON ONE PIECE OF
LIFE ADVICE, AND THIS REALLY IS
A BOOK OF LIFE ADVICE, TO OUR
VIEWERS, WHAT WOULD IT BE?
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
>> IF YOU PAY ATTENTION TO WHAT
YOU SAY, YOU WILL KNOW THAT
YOU ARE IN A SOLID PLACE,
SUPPOSE YOU ARE SPEAKING FROM
YOUR HEART.
OTHER TIMES YOU ARE SAYING
THINGS JUST TO LOOK GOOD AND
JUST TO BUTTRESS YOUR PARTICULAR
STATUS AT THE TIME, AND THAT
MAKES YOU FEEL WEAK.
YOU SELL YOURSELF OUT.
AND IF YOU PAY ATTENTION TO WHAT
YOU SAY, YOU CAN TELL WHEN
YOU'RE MAKING YOURSELF STRONGER,
YOU CAN TELL WHEN YOU'RE MAKING
YOURSELF WEAKER.
IN THE SEA WANT TO BE WEAKER,
THAN I WOULD SAY IT IS BEST TO
SAY THOSE THINGS THAT MAKE YOU S
SAY THOSE THINGS THAT MAKE YOU R
SAY THOSE THINGS THAT MAKE YOU N
SAY THOSE THINGS THAT MAKE YOU E
SAY THOSE THINGS THAT MAKE YOU .
YOU CAN LEARN TO DO THAT.
IT IS FAIRLY USEFUL.
SO I WOULD RECOMMEND PRACTICING
THAT BECAUSE IT IS GOOD FOR YOU
AND GOOD FOR EVERYONE ELSE TOO.